LAYS IN GENERAL WE ARE IN OUR
FRIDAY EDITION. WE'RE GONNA
HAVE A FEW MORE HEARINGS NEXT
WEEK THE MINUTE DEVICE YEARS
SAID THRILLED ABOUT THIS. YEAH.
TO BE MORE I THINK YOU SHOULD
SEE THAT YEAH EXACTLY. HEY
THERE YOU GO YEAH PLEASE GO
RIGHT AHEAD SIR. HOW IT IS. THE
REBEL WOULD YOU LIKE A CHAIRMAN
OF THE COMMITTEE. GO. I LIKE IT
ADD LET'S CALL THE ROLL AND
OPENS UP THE SAME JESTER. MORE
A LOT. MORE LIKE PRESENT
THEY'LL THEY'LL PRESENT.
HERTZBERG FURTADO NIELSEN
WIENER. TO BE ABLE TO CLOSE THE
ROLE WE'RE GOING TO RECESS THE
HEARING UNTIL AFTER SESSION I
WILL THEN ADD ON INDIVIDUALS
WHO MAY NOT BE ABLE TO VOTE
PRIOR TO THE NINE AM SESSION IF
OUR LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS THE
POLICY THAT'S IN FRONT OF US
HAS YET TO BE COMPLETED WILL
NEED TO BE ABLE TO HOLD THAT
OVER TILL THE- END OF SESSIONS
I JUST WANT TO GIVE A HEADS UP
AS WE- START MOVING FORWARD
WITH THAT. AND DO NOT WANT TO
RUSH THIS PROCESS SO WE DO HAVE
AN OPTION AS IT WILL BE
RELATIVELY QUICK SESSION
COMPARED TO WHAT WE'VE SEEN
EARLIER IN THE WEEK WE HAVE ONE
BILL IN FRONT OF US THAT'S AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN BEFORE WE
GET STARTED ON THIS I WANT TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY. HOW
GRATEFUL I AM I KNOW THAT
SENATOR WINNER IS ON BEHALF OF
AS IN NUMBER TWO. THE NUMBER
TWO HAS. BEEN WORKING ON THIS
ISSUE. DILIGENTLY FOR MANY
MONTHS NOW. THERE IS BEEN A
FORMAL AD HOC PROCESS THAT WERE
IT WAS ESTABLISHED TO BE ABLE
TO NEGOTIATE AND GO BACK AND
FORTH WITH THIS AND NUMBER TWO
ON AMENDMENTS HE IS STUCK TO
THAT GAME PLAN 1100% OF THE
TIME THROUGH THICK AND THIN IN
WHEN TIMES. WERE LOW HE
CONTINUED TO GO HI AND I JUST
WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY
HOW GRATEFUL WE ARE TO THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE SENATE VIRTUE
ON THIS IMPORTANT BILL HE'S
BEEN COLLABORATIVE HE'S BEEN
TRANSPARENT IN HE'S BEEN ABLE
TO FIND THE GET THIS IN FRONT
OF US WITH STAKEHOLDER INPUT
1100% OF THE WAY BOTH THROUGH
PUBLIC MEETINGS AS WELL AS TO
THE AD HOC PROCESS. ALSO ONE
TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU
SO MUCH TO THE CHAIR OF HOUSING
HERE IN THE SENATE SIDE CENTER
WIENER BUT FOR ALL OF HIS
COLLABORATION AND BETWEEN HIS
PERSPECTIVE TO THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE IN THIS WOULD NOT HAPPEN
WITHOUT EITHER THEM THE TWO
GOOD MEMBERS UP FROM CITY AND
COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO AND OF
COURSE WE HAVE NO THE GOOD
NUMBER ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM AS
WELL. BUT WITHOUT FURTHER DO
ONLY TURNED OVER THE CHAIR OF
THE ASSEMBLY HOUSING TO BE OUR
PRESENT AB FOURTEEN A SEVEN AND
AGAIN THANK YOU SIR FOR ALL OF
YOUR WORK. THANK YOU ELIMINATE
LET ME ALSO START BY BY FIRST
THING IN THE COMMITTEE FOR
GIVING ME AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REAP PERCENT THIS BILL AND OF
COURSE TO THANK THE CHAIR OF
THIS COMMITTEE WHO SPENT MANY
MANY HOURS NOT JUST WITH OUR
OFFICE BUT WITH STAKEHOLDERS
AROUND THE BAY IN YOUR DISTRICT
IN IN WORKING THIS THROUGH AND
WORKING THROUGH ALL THE ISSUES
ALSO WANNA JUST LIKE YOUR STAFF
WHO HAS DONE INCREDIBLE WORK
WORKING WITH OUR TEAM AND THE
REST OF THE BAY ON THIS. AND I
KNOW CENTER WINNER WAS HERE BUT
THANKS TO CENTER WIENER AND HIS
TEAM FOR MOVING THIS FORWARD SO
SENATORS THIS BILL AS A
REFRESHER IS A REGIONAL BILL TO
ADDRESS A HOUSING CRISIS IN OUR
BAY AREA. THE INTENT THE BILL
HAS BEEN TO ENABLE THE BAY AREA
TO HELP OURSELVES TO GIVE THE
NINE COUNTY REGION THE
AUTHORITY TO RAISE FUNDING. FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. SIMILAR TO
HOW THE REGION. HAS HAD
LEGISLATIVE AUTHORITY TO RAISE
MONIES FOR TRANSPORTATION
THANKS TO CENTER BILL. AS WELL
AS FOR RESTORATION OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY. OUR HOPE HAS
BEEN THROUGH THIS PROCESS THAT
THIS AUTHORITY WILL HELP TO
ADDRESS THE HOUSING PRICES IN
THE BAY AREA. WHERE WE HAVE
CONTINUE TO SUFFER FROM RECORD
HOME PRICES RENTS EVICTIONS AND
HOMELESSNESS LEVELS. WHEN WE
WERE LAST IN THIS COMMITTEE IN
EARLY JULY THE REGIONAL
AGENCIES WERE IN THE MIDST OF
CONTEMPLATING RECOMMENDED
AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL THAT
WOULD CONVEY THE SUPPORT OF A
BROAD RANGE OF CITIES AND
COUNTIES IN THE BAY AREA. AND I
AM GRATEFUL THAT WE HAVE THAT
TO DAY. WE HAD AT THE REQUEST
OF YOUR CHAIR. ESSENTIALLY
PAUSE THE BILL UNTIL WE RECEIVE
THAT FEEDBACK. THE REGIONAL
AGENCIES HAVE CONCLUDED THEIR
PROCESS IN JULY THEY VOTED TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL WITH THEIR
AMENDMENTS BY VOTE OF TWENTY
THREE TO THREE AT THE
ASSOCIATION OF BAY AREA
GOVERNMENTS. BY A VOTE OF
THIRTEEN A THREE AT THE
METROPOLITAN COMMISSION
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION. WE
HAVE SINCE INCORPORATED THEIR
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS AND WORK
CLOSELY WITH YOUR CHAIR. TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS THAT HE
HAD REYES WITH THIS BILL AND
THE BILL IN FRONT OF YOU
REFLECTS ALL OF THOSE CHANGES.
SOME OF THE HIGH LEVELS IN
TERMS OF GOVERNANCE WE'RE NOT
ESTABLISHING A NEW REGIONAL
AGENCY OR BUREAUCRACY WHICH WAS
WHAT WAS INITIALLY PROPOSED IN
THIS BILL MANY MANY MONTHS AGO
IN ITS FIRST. PRODUCTION
INSTEAD ALL MAJOR DECISIONS
RELATED TO THIS BILL RELATED TO
REVENUE AND EXPENDITURE. WILL
BE MADE BY A BAG AND THE M. T.
C. WITH A BAG. ACTING AS THE
LEAD AGENCY. IN TERMS OF
REVENUE THE SHARE FUNDS WILL BE
DISTRIBUTED DIRECTLY TO
COUNTIES. WITH A SHARE. THAT
HAS BEEN INCREASED FROM 75% TO
AT LEAST EIGHTY PERCENT.
REFLECTING A DESIRE FOR HIGHER
RETURN TO SOURCE. WITH
REMAINING 20% TO GO BACK TO THE
REGIONAL POOL WITH THE
EXCEPTION BEING A POTENTIAL.
TAX ON EMPLOYMENT WHERE 50%
WOULD GO BACK TO THE REGIONAL
POOL WHICH ENABLES OUR REGION
TO SUPPORT CITIES THAT FACE THE
BIRD OF HOUSING. THE WORK FORCE
THAT WE HAVE. IN ADDITION THE
THREE LARGEST CITIES IN THE
REGION WOULD GET AN ALLOCATION
OF FUNDS FROM THEIR COUNTIES
REFLECTING THEIR
DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE BURDEN
TO BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AND OTHER CITIES IN THE REGION
WOULD ALSO GET A GUARANTEED
FUNDING IF THEY HAVE MORE THAN
30% OF THEIR COUNTIES RENO
ALLOCATION. IN TERMS OF
EXPENDITURE WE HAVE AGREED
THREE MTC NAY BAGS AT LEAST.
TWO THIRDS OF THE FUNDING WOULD
BE DEDICATED TO PRODUCTION AND
PRESERVATION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND AGAIN THANKS TO THE
CHAIR FOR HIS. INPUT ON THAT.
AND ADDITIONAL MONIES WOULD BE
ALSO ABLE TO BE SPENT ON TENOR
PROTECTIONS INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
SUPPORTS HOUSING. AS WELL STAFF
SUPPORT. WE'RE EXCITED ABOUT
ALL THESE CHANGES TO THE BILL
WE'RE EXCITED ABOUT THE REGION
WIDE COLLABORATION AND WE OF
COURSE ARE COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING THE WORK. ON THIS
WITH THE REGION IN THE COMING
YEAR SO WITH THAT LIKE TO TURN
OVER TO OUR WITNESS. MS LONG
FROM THE MTC. GOOD MORNING
MA'AM YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES IS
GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN WE
APPRECIATE YOU MAKING THE TREK.
SACRAMENTO GAME MY PLEASURE. OF
REBEKAH LONG MANAGER OF
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS WITH HIM
TO SEE AN EIGHT. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR MCGUIRE IF I SHARE MORE
LIKE IN MEMBERS. WE'RE VERY
HAPPY TO BE DAY WITH A SUPPORT
POSITION ON A. B. FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN THIS HAS BEEN A
REMARKABLY. COLLABORATIVE
PROCESS WERE VERY GRATEFUL TO
THE AUTHORS AND THE NUMBER TWO
AND HIS STAFF. ON TV TO YOU
PERSONALLY MISTER CHAIR AND
YOUR STAFF. ON TO BRING US HERE
TODAY ON THIS BILL. REALLY HAS
BEEN WELL OUTLINED BY THE
AUTHOR SO I WON'T GO THROUGH
ALL OF THAT THEY'RE REALLY JUST
TO SAY HOW CRITICAL IT IS THAT
WE HAVE NOT JUST. ADDITIONAL
TOOLS IN TERMS OF ON. INCREASED
INCENTIVES TO BUILD HOUSING BUT
MORE RESOURCES NOW WE KNOW THAT
WE CAN'T SOLVE OUR HOUSING
CRISIS SIMPLY WITH. YOU KNOW
EFFORTS TO STREAMLINE
PRODUCTION FROM THE MARKET
RATE. ALL WE DO HAVE AN
ENORMOUS NEED TO BUILD MORE.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND THAT
DOES REQUIRE PUBLIC SUBSIDY.
I'M SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
IT DOESN'T ASK FOR ON THE STATE
TO RAISE TAXES. IT PROVIDES A
NEW TOOL TO REGIONAL AGENCIES
TO PUT MEASURES ON THE BALLOT.
ON THAT WOULD BE SUBJECT TO A
TWO THIRDS VOTE. ON AND ALSO
SUBJECT TO EXTENSIVE
COLLABORATION AND DISCUSSION AT
THE REGIONAL LEVEL SO NONE OF
THESE TAXES COULD MOVE FORWARD
WITHOUT APPROVAL OF BOTH
BOARDS. ON AND SO THAT'S AN
EXTENSIVE DEGREE OF LOCAL
ENGAGEMENT THAT WOULD BE
REQUIRED SO WITH THAT IN JUST A
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
AND ASK YOUR AYE VOTE AND- WITH
MUCH GRATITUDE FOR ALL THE WORK
TO BRING US HERE TODAY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH WHEN WE OPEN IT UP
FOR THOSE WHO MAY BE IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU COULD PLEASE ADVANCE
THIS TIME LOOKING FOR THOSE IN
SUPPORT THE BILL. GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF FREMONT. SAN LEANDRO
OAKLAND AND BERKELEY THAT'S THE
LEGACY OF CRANKS THANK THANK
YOU SO MUCH GOOD MORNING.
RUNNING HOLLY FOR MANY TO HIS
SERVICE PROVIDERS PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF NPH
HABITAT FOR AMENITIES BASIL
CONNELLY. SB AT HOME AND
CALIFORNIA CAN BE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH GOOD MORNING. JULIE CENTER
ON BEHALF OF ENTERPRISE
COMMUNITY PARTNERS A CO SPONSOR
THANK YOU THANK YOU. FOR ANY
LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT. WE'RE NOT GONNA ASK
THOSE WHO MAY BE IN OPPOSED IF
YOU COULD PLEASE ADVANCE THIS
TIME. MORNING SURE MEMBERS IN
TWENTY. CDI A FIRST ONE I THINK
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHURCH YOU
MIGHT JUST BRING THE MIKE UP
CLOSER I'M SORRY AS ONE MAKE
SURE WE GET WORDS I APOLOGIZE
FOR INTERRUPTING FORCE OR
MYSELF BUT I. CAN HEAR YEAH
YOU'RE GOOD. SO I JUST INJURED
BECAUSE IT OUR CVA FIRST WE
WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHIU AND ALL THE STAFF WORKING
WITH US AND GRACIOUS.
GRACIOUSLY GIVING US THEIR
LIMITED TIME SINCE THE NEWS
AMENDMENTS WENT TO PRINT LAST
WEEK. WE REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
THE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS TAKEN THE
TIME TO HEAR OUR CONCERNS. AND
TO CONSIDER POSSIBLE REMEDIES.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE'S A
LOOPHOLE OR HOUSING CAN BE
TAXED IN THE BAY AREA WHICH-
CAN ULTIMATELY HAVE AN IMPACT
ON OUR FOLKS FOR THESE REASONS
WE ARE. SEE I AS AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH APPRECIATE BEING
HERE GOOD MORNING SIR. GOOD
MORNING CASEY ELITE ON BEHALF
OF THOSE TOWNS OF LAFAYETTE.
PLEASANTON IN DANVILLE WERE IN
OPPOSITION. OUR PRIMARY
OPPOSITION STEMS FROM THE
RETURN TO SOURCE ON THE
FUNDING. AS IS CURRENTLY IN THE
BILL THE FUNDS WOULD RETURN. TO
THE COUNTY OF ORIGIN. A WE
BELIEVE IT WOULD BE MORE
APPROPRIATE FOR SOME OF A
PORTION OF THOSE FUNDS TO
RETURN DIRECTLY TO THE CITIES
OF ORIGIN. SO THAT WAY THE
PROPERTY TAX OWNERS THE
BUSINESSES THAT ARE PAYING
THESE TAXES CAN HAVE SOME LEVEL
OF ASSURANCE. THAT THEY WILL BE
RECEIVING FUNDS BACK. THEREFORE
THEY CAN GAUGE IN SOME LONG
TERM PLANNING THOSE TYPES OF
THINGS. THANK YOU NO THANK YOU
SO MUCH. WOULD LIKE TO GO TO DO
A LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO MAY
BE. OPPOSED IF YOU COULD PLEASE
COMPORT LAST CALL FOR POST.
LIKE TO BE TO BRING IT BACK
WOULD JUST LIKE TO JUST QUICKLY
IN A TURN OVER THE COMMITTEE.
ON THE ISSUE RETURN TO SOURCE
THIS WAS A- A REALLY BIG
DISCUSSION FOR. A FEW WEEKS
DURING THE NEGOTIATIONS ON THIS
I THINK THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
STRIKE A BALANCE. WE'RE ABLE TO
KEEP THE LARGEST CITIES IN THE
BAY AREA. SAN JOSE OAKLAND AND
SAN FRANCISCO. CONTINUE TO SEE
MONEY FLOW DIRECTLY BACK. BUT
WE ALSO HEARD FROM SOME SMALL
CITIES THAT SAID THAT. THEY MAY
NOT BE ABLE TO HANDLE THE
DOLLARS. THAT MAY BE FLOWING
BACK. AND CANDIDLY. I THOUGHT
WE NEEDED TO BE A TO DO MORE.
SO WE TOOK A DATA DRIVEN
APPROACH WHEN IT COMES TO THE
ISSUE OF RETURN TO SOURCE. IN
WHAT WE. ENDED UP SAYING IS IF
THERE IS ANY CITY THAT HAS OVER
30% OF THE ENTIRE FOR WHAT
HOUSING STOCK. WITHIN THEIR
COUNTY THEY WOULD GET DIRECT
RETURN TO SOURCE SO THAT WOULD
MEAN LIKE FOR EXAMPLE SANTA
ROSA WHO IS 54% OF ALL
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE
COUNTY CINEMA WOULD ALSO BE
ELIGIBLE. THAT WOULD MEAN NAPA
WHAT HAS 53% OF ALL FOR MY
HOUSE IN THE COUNTY WOULD GET
THAT DIRECT. BUT THE COUNTY
WOULD WORK COLLABORATIVELY WITH
THOSE SMALLER CITIES THAT WAS A
BIG ISSUE WHICH I THINK THAT WE
ARE ABLE TO WORK THROUGH
OBVIOUSLY THEY'RE GOING TO BE
SOME. WHO WILL STILL HAVE SOME
CONCERNS IN THE OTHER ITEM I
WILL IN NO OPENING UP IS I WILL
NOT GO THROUGH. AS I DID AT
HOUSING IN AGAIN I WANNA SING
GREAT RESPECT TO ARE THE
ADVOCATES WHO ARE HERE ON
BEHALF OF CIA I WOULD TO SHARE
MY FRUSTRATION I PROMISE YOU I
WILL NOT GO INTO WHAT I SAID AT
HOUSING. IS THAT THIS WAS VERY
LAST MINUTE AND DO BELIEVE THAT
THOSE CONCERNS CAN BE WORED
OUT AT A LOCAL LEVEL AS THIS
INITIATIVE THAT WERE IT THAT'S
IN FRONT OF US TODAY. IT'S
SIMPLY PROVIDING. PERMISSION TO
BE ABLE TO ADVANCE. ANY
POTENTIAL REVENUE MEASURE.
REVENUE MEASURE WOULD NEED TO
BE PUT ON TO THE BALLOT BY A
BAG IN MTC. PRIOR TO ANY OF THE
REVENUE MEASURES GOING IN FRONT
OF THE BAY AREA VOTERS THEY
WOULD NEED TO BE DEBATED AND
DISCUSSED PUBLICLY AND
ULTIMATELY WHAT ENDS UP IN
THOSE MEASURES WILL BE TO THE
REPRESENTATIVES OF A BAG IN IN
DC. SO LONG STORY SHORT. THOSE
CONCERNS CAN STILL BE ADDRESSED
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL PRIOR TO A
POTENTIAL MEASURE BEING PUT ON
TO THE BALLOT. I'M GONNA STOP
YAPPING AND TURN IT OVER I TO
ANY MEMBERS WHO WOULD LIKE ME
TO SPEAK IN ALSO WELCOME MOTION
IN BEFORE CENTER BELL SPEAKS I
JUST WANT TO SAY. THERE'S BEEN
A BIGGER CHAMPION OF FOR MY
HOUSE AND THEN SENATE ABOUT
THANK YOU. FOR ALL YOUR WORK
SIR. OKAY ONE OF THE ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS I HAD WITH THE
REVISED BILL. WAS WHAT IS THE
CAN YOU DESCRIBE THE PUBLIC
PROCESS. THAT HAPPENS BEFORE
THE BALLOT MEASURE. AND THEN
THE PUBLIC PROCESS ONCE THE
BALLOT MEASURES APPROVED AFTER
THE BALLOT MEASURE. COULD. YOU
CAN YOU GO OVER THAT FOR ME
LIKE SO OR AND THEN AFTER
SEARCHES AND A VERY QUICK LEVEL
THAT SORT OF HIGH LEVEL AS YOUR
CHAIR HAD HIGHLIGHTED THERE ARE
TWO MAJOR REGIONAL BODIES IN
THE BAY AREA WHICH SIR BILL
KNOWS WELL. A BAG AND THE EMPTY
SEAT AND IN ORDER FOR THIS TO
BE APPROVED A BIG WOULD START
THE PROCESS OF PROPOSING
POTENTIAL REVENUE MEASURES AND
DETAILS OF AN EXPENDITURE PLAN
IT WOULD HAVE TO BE APPROVED BY
A BACK THAT THEN WOULD GO TO
THE MTC THAT YOU SERVED ON FOR
SIMILAR APPROVAL IF THE MTC.
DECIDES THAT THEY WANT CHANGES
TO THAT IT WOULD HAVE TO THEN
GO BACK TO THE A BACK FOR FINAL
APPROVAL BEFORE IT WOULD GO TO
VOTERS FOR TWO THIRDS VOTE AND
SO ISRAEL NO TWO THIRDS VOTES
AT THE BALLOT BOX ARE
DIFFICULT. I AND WOULD REQUIRE
COULD SIGNIFICANT CONSENSUS WE
ALSO KNOW THAT HAMMER NOT
CONSENSUS A BACK AN MTC OR ALSO
DIFFICULT SO THAT'S AT A HIGH
LEVEL THE PROCESS. WHEN YOU SEE
A BAG WHICH BODY OF A BAG OR
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE EXACT
APART OKAY THAT'S WHAT I WANTED
TO FIND OUT YES OKAY SO THEN
ONCE. THE TWO BODIES. AGREE
UPON. THAT IT GOES ON THE
BALLOT AS DESCRIBED BY THE TWO
BODIES. THEN THE VOTERS APPROVE
IT THEN IN TERMS OF THE ON
GOING. KIND OF ALLOCATION THE
PLAN AND SO FORTH WHAT IS THE
PUBLIC PROCESS OF OUR HOUSE
THAT PROCEDURALLY GO WE WELL
FIRST OF ALL WE OUTLINED
SEVERAL OF THE DETAILS OF WHAT
THEY NEED TO LOOK LIKE SO FOR
EXAMPLE AT THE SUGGESTION OF
CENTER MCGUIRE TWO THIRDS THAT
MONEY HAVE TO GO TO PRODUCTION
OF PRESERVATION. OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. EXCUSE ME. THE MONEY'S
AWARD YOU HEARD THIS DISCUSSION
AROUND MONIES THAT WOULD BE
GOING TO COUNTIES VERSUS MONIES
THAT WOULD BE GOING TO A
REGIONAL POT. THAT ALL GETS
THAT'LL AT SOME OF THE HIGHER
POINTS OF THAT HAVE BEEN SET BY
THIS BILL SO. OUT FOR MANY THE
REVENUE SOURCES 80% OF THE
MONIES WOULD BE RETURNED TO
SOURCE WOULD GO TO THE COUNTIES
WHERE THEY CAME FROM. 20% WOULD
GO TO A REGIONAL POT WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF ONE REVENUE SOURCE
WHICH WOULD BE A BUSINESS
RELATED SOURCE IN THE IDEAS
WHERE THOSE JOBS ARE CREATED.
HALF OF THAT MONEY SHOULD GO TO
REGIONAL POT TO ADDRESSES
CONCERNS IS THAT IS THAT YOUR
QUESTION. PROCESS THAT YOU GO
THROUGH OKAY THE BALLOT
MEASURES APPROVED OKAY WE GOT
ALL THE STUFF IN THE LAW
APPROVED IT THE YOU HAVE THE
AYE THOSE STATUTES JEFF TO
OBSERVE THEN YOU HAVE A BODY
THAT ALLOCATES THE MONEY TO
CITIES COUNTIES HE'S FROM UP
AND WANT TO HUNDRED DO. THEY GO
AND MAKE. US FOR AYE AYES AND.
HOW IS THE SO YOU HAVE AN
OVERALL OF STRATEGIC PLAN SO
COUNTIES WOULD DETERMINE RING
ON THIS JACK COUNTIES WOULD
DETERMINE AN EXPENDITURE PLAN.
AND THAT WOULD GO THROUGH THE
PUBLIC PROCESS SO SANTA CLARA
COUNTY. SAN FRANCISCO COUNTY
EXCEPT FOR A WOOD FIGURE OUT
THE POT OF MONEY THAT COMES IN.
AND HAVE THAT DISCUSSION
OBVIOUSLY WITH THEIR CITIES UP
FOR THAT PART OF MONEY. OKAY
THEY WOULD HAVE TO HAVE A
PUBLIC HEARING EACH COUNTERACT
ABSOLUTELY THEY HAVE TO GO TAKE
THAT PLAN WHATEVER THE AGREE ON
AND GET THE. THE ORIGINAL BODY
TO APPROVE THE PLAN AFTER THE
AGREED TO IT. I WAS AT WORK.
YEAH I THINK THAT EXPENDITURE
PLAN WOULD SIMPLY HAVE TO BE
CONFIRMED THAT IT'S COMPLETED
BUT IT'S WITH REGARD TO THE
DISCRETION OF THE COUNTY. OKAY
SO THAT WAS SOMETHING. MAYBE
THEY WANT TO DO SOMETHING A
CERTAIN WAY THEY CAN DO IT
WITHOUT HAVING DOT OVER WRITTEN
BY THE REGIONAL BODY THAT'S
RIGHT THEY WOULD HAVE TO COMPLY
WITH THE TERMS OF THIS BILL BUT
YES. OKAY YEAH. AND OKAY SO THE
COUNTY WOULD HAVE THE SPECIFIC.
ALLOCATION YOU KNOW LIKE IF
THERE IS. TWENTY TWO CITIES.
AND THEY WANTED TO ALLOCATED TO
ALL TWENTY TWO CITIES THANKS TO
THAT OUT OR THEY CAN ALLOCATED
TO PROJECTS OR COULD THEY ARE
THEY ALLOCATED TO PROJECTS OR
TO COMMUNITIES. THERE ARE LIKE
IS THERE LIKE ASSEMBLY COMES AT
AN ONCE. ROGER TO APPROVED DO
THEY ALLOCATED TO THAT ORDER
THE ALLOCATED TO THE CITIES AND
THEN THE CITY'S ALLOCATED TO
THE PROJECTS. ALL THIS CAR.
IT'S ACTUALLY AS IT'S AS THE
COUNTY SEE FIT OF THEIR
PROJECTS THAT WOULD BE LIKELY
BROUGHT FORWARD BY CITIES BUT
GENERALLY WOULD BE EITHER
PROJECTS OR CITIES OKAY. AND.
MESSAGE QUESTIONS GET A CLEARER
SO IF THE COUNTY WATER TO
ALLOCATED TO A HOUSING TRUST
DIRECTLY TO THE ALLOCATED TO
HOUSING TRUST. IF THEY WANTED
TO DO THAT IS THAT ALLOWED
UNDER THE I BELIEVE THAT IS I
JUST WANT TO CONFIRM MY STAFF
IS CONFIRMING THAT YES THERE'S
A LOT OF CASES ARE COUNTY WOULD
PROBABLY JUST OUT. YOU KNOW THE
SMALLER CITIES. THE WOULD
PREFER. TO NOT BE IN CHARGE OF
MANAGING THE MONEY AND DOING
ALL THE PROCESS THEY DID TURN
IT OVER TO THE- ON A HOUSING
TRUST. THEN THE COUNTY HOUSING
TRUST WOULD BE MORE EFFICIENT.
ALLOCATED TO AND REVIEW THE
PROJECTS AND THEN ALLOCATE THE
MONEY TO THOSE AND THAT'S
EXACTLY WHY ACER REQUIRE AND I
HAD HAD HAD THOUGHT THAT THE
FORMULA MADE SENSE FOR THE SOME
OF THE LARGEST CITIES TO
RECEIVE A DIRECT ALLOCATION BUT
OTHERWISE TO GIVE THE COUNTIES
THE DISCRETION TO FIGURE OUT
THE MOST EFFICIENT WAY. TO GET
IT TO THE PROJECTS THAT WOULD
BEST HELP BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE MANY CITIES AS YOU
PUT IT THAT DON'T HAVE THE
EXPERTISE I DON'T HAVE HOUSING
DEPARTMENT THE WHERE WITH ALL
OR THE INTEREST TO DO IT AND
YET THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
NEEDS STILL EXIST. OKAY OKAY
THAT'S GOOD I ANSWERED THE AS
ALL MY QUESTIONS THAT I HEARD
OUT OF MY COMMUNITY AND THANK
YOU FIRST BILL AND I MOVED
THROUGH THE BILL. FOR THANK YOU
SO MUCH CENTER BELL THE MEMBERS
ANY GONNA DO A QUICK ON QUICK
TIME CHECK WE HAVE CENTER TARA
CENTER NIELSEN WHO'D LIKE THAT
COMMENT WOULD ALSO LIKE TO BE A
HAD TO. CHAIR HOUSES IN A
WINNER IF YOU'D LIKE TO BE A
COMMON AS WELL ON THIS SO WE
ARE. GOING TO NEED TO RECESS.
AT APPROXIMATELY NINE AM. BE
ABLE TO GET TO THE FLOOR. SO I
JUST WANNA BE WHERE AN THAT
TURN OVER CENTER OR TITLE THEN
WE'RE GONNA GO TO SENATOR
NIELSEN. QUICK QUESTION AND
THEN FOLLOWED BY STATEMENT. THE
BILL IS JUST PACIFIC TO THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA WHICH MEANS
THAT COUNTIES OF ALAMEDA CONTRA
COSTA MARIN NAPA THE NINE
COUNTY REGIONS OF THE BAY
CORRECT YOU KNOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TO AYE. YOU PROBABLY
KNOW THIS BY NOW I'M NOT A BIG
FAN OF INCREASING TAXES OR FEES
BUT I REALLY DO ADMIRE YOU KNOW
YOUR HARD WORK AND TRYING TO.
YOU KNOW AFTER FOR HOUSING FOR
YOUR FOR YOUR DISTRICT IN YOUR
REGION AND SO. FOR THOSE
REASONS TODAY I WILL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR YOUR YOUR BILL
SO. JUST WANTED TO. IT JUST
WANTED TO ASK IN AND PUT AND
LET YOU KNOW THAT AS WELL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER TARA.
MORNING CENTER NIELSEN UPGRADE
AND I HAD A FOOTHOLD IN THIS
AREA MANY YEARS AGO IN FACT WAS
EVEN A MEMBER OF THE CDC KNOWS
THE CDC STILL ALIVE AND WELL I
SERVED ON THE CDC. AFTER YOU
DID SO YES IT IS WELL HERE'S
THE ISSUE. I DON'T. THINK
THERE'S ANYTHING IN THIS
LEGISLATION THAT WOULD HELP.
EXPEDITE OR RELIEVE SOME OF THE
COST ADD ONS THAT HAVE BEEN A
MAJOR CONTRIBUTING FACTOR LIKE
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS SO. AND
SAID THIS IS GOING TO BE TOUTED
AS A MODEL FOR ALL OF
CALIFORNIA IT'S GOING TO BE
PRETTY TOUGH FOR ME TO VOTE FOR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT IS THERE
ANYTHING IN HERE THAT WILL FAST
TRACK CONSTRUCTION. TO GET SOME
OF THE THINGS THAT CONCERN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY OUT OF
THE WAY OR RELIEVE THEIR
BURDENS AND THE IMPEDIMENTS IN
THE LITIGATION. CENTER WINNER
AS A BILL HE'D LIKE TO TALK
ABOUT. PLEASE A SIMILAR TO SO
THIS OF THIS BILL IS ABOUT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FUNNY THERE
IS A PORTION OF POTENTIAL
EXPENDITURES THAT WOULD PROVIDE
CITIES WITH ESSENTIALLY TECH
THE 10% OF THE POOL COULD BE
USED FOR INCENTIVES TO CITIES.
THAT ARE DOING A BETTER JOB OF
BUILDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING SO
BROADLY SPEAKING YOU KNOW THE
IDEAS THAT COUNTIES WOULD BE
MAKING DECISIONS ON WHERE TO
BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING WITHIN
THEIR- WITHIN THEIR REGION AND-
WOULD ALSO BE AND- THEY WOULD
BEAT IN CENTER TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT WHAT. WHAT WOULD COLUSA
FOR THE HOUSING PRODUCTION
WITHIN WITHIN THOSE REGIONS BUT
I WILL SEND A DIFFERENT FRONT
ON THOSE ON THOSE TOPICS I
THINK WE SHARE THE SAME POLICY
GOALS I'VE BEEN VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF. MOVING FOR A CONVERSATION
AS A CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY
HOUSING COMMITTEE ON WHAT TO DO
AROUND IMPACT FEES AS WELL AS
HOW DO WE STREAMLINED HOUSING
WE KNOW. THAT A SIGNIFICANT
HOUSING PRODUCTION IS THE ONLY
LONG TERM SOLUTION I HAD HOPED
THAT WE WERE GOING TO SEE
CENTER WINNERS BILL COPPER TORE
HOUSE I HOPE THAT THERE WILL
BE. SIGNIFICANT PRODUCTION
BILLS MOVING FORWARD THAT WE
CAN TIE TO THIS SO WE CERTAINLY
SHARE THOSE POLICY GOALS. I
THANK OF. SALMON TO ANAHEIM
WHERE. FOR STATE. TODAY I AM
NOT REPORTER. THANK YOU SO MUCH
TENDERNESS IN VERY GRATEFUL
THANK YOU VERY TURN OVER TO
CENTER WINNER PLAYERS QUICKLY
SO WE CAN GET TO THE FLOOR I
WANT TO THANK MY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. HE HE ALWAYS SMILES AND
REYES. IF I IF I FIXES BOTTLES
AND HE FIXES MINE ON HIS
SENATOR SO. FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
THIS IS BEEN A REALLY HARD BILL
I'M OR ONE ONE WHEN WAS FIRST
PROPOSED THERE'S A LOT OF
SKEPTICISM. ABOUT IT BUT THE
AUTHOR HAS REALLY ASSIST AND
I'M PROUD TO BE A CO AUTHOR OF
THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT ALL THIS
DOES. IS SAYS TO THE BAY AREA
THAT IF THE VOTERS OF THE BAY
AREA WANT TO GO BY A TWO THIRDS
VOTE. THE FUNDS AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR LOWER INCOME
RESIDENTS IN THE VOTERS OF THE
BAY AREA SHOULD BE ABLE WITH A
TWO THIRDS VOTE. ODD TO DO THAT
AND I THINK. THAT REGIONAL
AUTONOMY TO. MEET A REALLY DEEP
CREDIT BECAUSE THE CRISIS
EVERYWHERE IN CALIFORNIA BUT
THE BAY AREA. IS A SPECIAL KIND
OF CRISIS IT'S REALLY BAD. SHE
FOR LOWER INCOME RESIDENTS WERE
BEING PUSHED IN THE
HOMELESSNESS. AND HI. IN TERMS
THE COST OF THE QUESTION FROM
THE US FROM I CENTER NIELSEN.
ON RIGHT NOW IN CALIFORNIA
UNDER SB THIRTY FIVE WHICH I
AUTHORED TWO YEARS AGO.
ESSENTIALLY A 100% AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. REALLY ANYTHING THAT'S
AT LEAST 50% AFFORDABLE. IS
STREAMLINED. ESSENTIALLY IN ALL
OF CALIFORNIA WITH ONLY MINOR
EXCEPTIONS NO SEQUEL NO
DISCRETIONARY PERMITTING. NODE
LAWSUITS AROUND SEE WHAT. IT'S
ALL TAKEN OUT OF THAT
STREAMLINED. AND THEN THE
AUTHOR ACTUALLY SOMEONE OR TO
AUTHORED LEGISLATION SPECIFIC
TO SUPPORT OF HOUSING FOR
FORMALLY HOMELESS PEOPLE. SO WE
HAVE MASSIVELY STREAMLINED THE
HOUSING THAT WOULD BE FUNDED BY
THIS MEASURE SO JUST TO POINT
THAT OUT. SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I'M A STRONG SUPPORTER
OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE VICE
CHAIR MS RUSH. THE COMMISSION
SURE THIS IS THE FOURTH HEARING
WE'VE HAD ON THIS BILL. SO I
JUST WANNA LET YOU KNOW THAT
I'M TRYING TO CATCH THE VISION
AND MY ISSUE IS THAT I'M NOT
FAMILIAR WITH THE PLAYERS IN
YOUR REGION SO I HAVEN'T HAD
THAT PERSONAL TOUCH THAT YOU
HAVE. A SO I'M A LITTLE
CONCERNED I DON'T HAVE A
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA COMPARED OF
AYE I DID SERVE ON THE CTA
BOARDED SERVE ON O. C. COG
WHICH PROBABLY THE- THE
COMPARABLE. TO WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE NOT TO SURE
I'D BE EXCITED ABOUT THAT
PROPOSITION OF THIS MODEL DOWN
THERE WITH THOSE TWO.
MUNICIPALITIES SO I'M I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT WE'RE
DOING IS A PRESIDENT BEEN
LISTENING I'VE BEEN ABSTAINING
ARE LAYING OFF. A EACH TIME.
BUT IT'S A BIG STATE AND WE
HAVE TO LOOK AT BEST PRACTICES.
AND I'M JUST CONCERNED ABOUT A
BOTTOM UP VERSUS THE TOP DOWN.
MAYBE IT'S BETTER TO GO BOTTOM
UP THAN THAT. YOU KNOW HAVEN'T
CAM DIRECTED OUT OF SACRAMENTO
ON HOW THINGS SHOULD BE DONE
BUT I'M- I'M I'M A LITTLE.
CONCERNED I'M NOT SURE IF THIS
IS THE BEST APPROACH AND I.
APOLOGIZE I MISSED YOUR THAT
I'M READING IT AND LOOKING AT
EVERY. EVERY MEETING I'M I'M
I'M HERE AND I'M LISTENING. BUT
I DON'T KNOW IF WE HAVE TIME
YEARS TO WATCH IT FAIL OR
SUCCEED. BECAUSE OF THE NEEDS
SO I. I MAY BE LEANING MORE
TOWARDS A NO AND I JUST WANTED
TO PUT THAT ON THE RECORD THANK
YOU MISTER. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER VICE CHAIR VERY GRATEFUL
FOR YOUR COMMENTS. AS IN GERMAN.
SEEN IN HEARING ALL DISCUSSION
DEBATE SEES WE DO HAVE A MOTION
ON THE FLOOR THAT MOTION IS BY
SENATOR BAIL. THE MOTION IS
RETURN THE BILL TO THE SENATE
FLOOR. I WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT
TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE GERMAN
TO MY LEFT JONATHAN FOR ALL OF
HIS WORK ON THIS. HE HAS BEEN
WORKING. MANY MANY HOURS WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU TO STEVE FROM.
THE ASSEMBLY SIDE FOR ALL OF
HIS WORK ON THIS. WE ARE GOING
TO BE RECESSED SCENES COMMITTEE
FORMALLY. AS WILL BE ADDING
NINE. SENATOR HERTZBERG AFTER
SESSION WE'RE GONNA BE
RECONVENING IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE. SIMILAR CHIU WOULD
YOU LIKE TO BE ABLE TO CLOSE.
JUST VERY BRIEFLY I'M HAPPY TO
CONTINUE ENGAGE IN A
CONVERSATION WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES ACROSS THE I WILL
SAY WE NEVER INTENDED THIS TO
BE A MODEL FOR OTHER. REGIONS
WHERE SIMPLY TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT WORKS FOR THE BAY.
OBVIOUSLY BUT DOES WORK WELL
THAN HAPPY FOR OTHERS TO LOOK
AT IT BUT REST ASSURED I'M NOT
TRYING TO. TO PUSH THIS MODEL.
THAT BEING SAID IT IS FOR THE
BAY AREA WE'VE DONE THIS FOR
TRANSPORTATION WE'VE DONE THIS
FOR BAY AREA RESTORATION. IT
HAS WORKED VERY WELL. I WOULD
DESCRIBE THIS BILL. NOT AS A
TOP DOWN. BUT AS THE BOTTOM UP.
WE RE ENGAGE. MORE DEEPLY THAN
I'VE ENGAGE. WITH ANY BILL I'VE
HAD. IT FIVE YEARS WITH. REAL
GRASSROOTS. LEADER PASSED CHOIR
HAS. PAINSTAKINGLY MEN INVOLVED
IN MANY OF THESE MEETINGS WITH
WITH LOCAL LEADERS AS HAS
CENTER. WIENER TOOK TO MAKE
SURE THAT. THIS GIVES THE
LOCALS REALLY GIVES OUR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THE TOOL TO
FIGURE THIS OUT FOR THEMSELVES.
SALE TO PAY FOR THE IF YOU'RE
NOT FROM THE BEAR. SO THAT
THOSE OF US FOR THE BAY AREA.
WILL WILL WILL HOPEFULLY. I
HAVE SLIGHTLY LESS PRESSURES
WHEN IT COMES TO BUDGETARY
NEEDS AND OTHERS. WHICH AGAIN
FREEZE FREEZE UP I THINK
BUDGETARY RESOURCES FOR THE
REST OF THE STATE SO WITH THAT.
LET ME AGAIN REITERATE MY DEEP
DEEP THANKS TO THE CHAIRMAN.
FOR HIS INCREDIBLE WORK ALSO
JUST TAKE A NOTE AND THINK MY
STAFFERS THE WARTIME AND ANYONE
ELSE IN OUR WIENER. WHO HAVE
ENGAGE COUNTLESS HOURS ON THIS
AND THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH
IF SOMEONE WERE THANK YOU DEAR
WORK THANK YOU CENTER WIENER
VERY GRATEFUL. WHEN CHESTER
RECALL PLEASE. BY WIRE I'M MORE
LONG. BELL BILL I HERTZBERG HER
TITLE HELLO I NIELSEN. WIENER
WIENER HI. IT IS CURRENTLY FOUR
ZERO VOTE WE'RE GONNA KEEP THE
BILL OPEN LACING GENERAL GONNA
RECESS WE WILL BE RECONVENING
AT THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
FIFTEEN MINUTES AFTER SESSION
ROOM. THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
FIFTEEN MINUTES AFTER SESSIONS.
WE ARE IN RECESS
CONVENING THE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE HERE AND WE-
HAVE. THE MAJORITY LEADER IS IN
THE HOUSE TODAY BUT IN GENERAL
WE CURRENTLY ENJOY A FOUR ZERO
VOTE ON OUR ONE NINE AND EIGHTY
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN THE
MOTIONS RETURN THE BILL TO THE
SENATE FLOOR MISSING JUST IF
YOU CAN PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG
GUY. THE GENTLEMAN THAT IS DONE
FIVE ZERO VOTE THAT BILL IS OUT
WE'RE CLOSE AND ROLL THANK YOU
SO MUCH WE'RE GONNA BE. SENIOR
PROBABLY SEVERAL TIMES THIS
WEEK WHICH AS THE MAJORITY
LEADER. AND ARE TRANSPORTATION
HERE IS VERY EXCITED ABOUT. NOW
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH
HAVE A WONDERFUL WEEKEND WE ARE
JR